a warning that this report from our
crime correspondent martin brunt does
contain some flashing images
it's hardly been a secret the german
drifter has been the main suspect in the
madeline mccann case for three years or
more but now it's official
christian b is suspected of abducting
and killing madeleine
german prosecutors are leading the
investigation but haven't charged him
the british girl was three when she
vanished from the family's holiday
apartment in portugal in 2007 15 years
ago
this week the suspect had visitors to
the german prison where he's serving a
rape sentence he was told that
portuguese prosecutors had made him an
arguedo a formal suspect
he was questioned for the first time but
refused to answer
why now
well in portugal there's a statute of
limitations of 15 years on prosecuting
serious crimes
the authorities there may want their own
trial in my opinion this isn't just
procedural i don't accept that you know
this is them taking a box to keep the
the the door open given what i know
about the the approach of the portuguese
authorities on this case and and the
seriousness with which it's now taken
and i am sure that made a a judgment and
i hope that this opens the door for for
them to apply for extradition
there have been other arguments notably
madeleine's parents kate and jerry later
ruled out as suspects no charges have
been brought
against them
the investigation continues
and robert murat who lived near the
mccann apartment he too was cleared of
all suspicion christian b's lawyer
played down the development he said this
move by the portuguese authorities
should not be overstated
i assume this step will interrupt the
statute of limitations
it is not a charge and it may well be
that the status is revoked
they perhaps have themselves found some
significant new evidence
that
may
bolster the case against christian b and
it may be that they want to work
cooperatively with the germans to now
move forward on this
christian bee says he's innocent and is
expected to claim he was elsewhere on
the night madeleine mccann vanished
marty brunt sky news
well there's been some reaction from
madeleine's parents this evening kate
and jerry mccann have welcomed the
latest news saying it does reflect
progress in the investigation they also
said we are kept informed of
developments by the metropolitan police
it is important to note the arguedo has
not yet been charged with any specific
crime related to madeleine's
disappearance even though the
possibility may be slim we have not
given up hope that madeleine is still
alive and we will be reunited
with her